ukraine
passed yesterday a law to legalize
cryptocurrencies uh if you think about
this it's pretty crazy that it wasn't
legal already uh but the main purpose uh
behind the bill is to provide
clarification on the asset and protect
those who owned bitcoin as it was not
previously legal um or illegal so
basically it was up in the air nobody
knew uh but this bill gives the citizens
permission to own and trade bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies on exchanges
according to the bill
this law regulates legal relations
arising in connection with the turnover
of virtual assets in ukraine defines the
rights and obligations of participants
in the virtual assets market the
principles of state policy in the field
of virtual assets
what
every time i read anything that a
government writes i just say why can't
they just write in plain english why
they got to make it so confusing this
law regulates legal relations what the
hell is a legal relationship i did not
have sexual relations with that woman
come on what is this legal relationship
just say that the law allows people to
buy and sell bitcoin like i look there
you go i solved your problem the page
would be so much shorter if you just
wrote it in english
uh you are salty today i'm just gonna
call it how it is today today is one of
those days where there's no filter i'm
just going to say what i what i think
bill was drafted last year it passed
with 276 lawmakers uh supporting the law
only six were against it those six must
be boomers this is the fifth country in
the last few weeks to lay down some
ground rules for the cryptocurrency
market obviously el salvador made it
legal tender cuba passed a law to
recognize well we got a spell recognized
right there maybe next time and regulate
cryptocurrencies panama's kicking around
a draft of its own cryptocurrency law
and then ukraine is the second largest
country by size eighth by population in
europe and yeah uh in europe and they've
got 45 million people as of 2019.
when you when you look at this there's a
couple of things that immediately pop to
mind first the bills are written in a
ridiculous legal legalese language that
no one understands so they probably
would be better off if they changed that
two it is not lost on me that the
country of ukraine is giving permission
to their citizens to use a
permissionless technology
the law doesn't matter
for the technology to be used or not now
they can go after people right in
nigeria or pakistan where they actually
have banned or outlawed bitcoin they can
go and they can try to put people in
jail they can regulate businesses etc
but they can't stop people from using
the technology it's a permissionless
technology you do not need permission to
access it
and so the idea that the country gives
people permission is quite
funny there's irony to it and then
lastly is uh when you think of ukraine
uh i think i saw stat uh that said
ukraine is the
fourth most popular
country hold on
we're we're gonna do some live research
real quick
according to chain analysis ukraine is
fourth worldwide when it comes to per
capita crypto adoption
that's pretty big right nick carter
posted a uh chain analysis uh blog so
ukraine is the fourth
worldwide when it comes to per capita
crypto adoption so very very large
crypto adoption and so i think that
this is ultimately like the will of the
people wins right if you remember like
uh uber when uber went to new york city
the people loved it they were like oh my
god taxis suck uber's so much better
let's all use uber and uber was also
subsidizing both the riders fare and
also the driver so drivers getting paid
more money the riders loved it because
it was cheap uh it was better than a
taxi et cetera well the government hated
uber and the taxi unions were up in arms
or protests and all kinds of crazy stuff
trying to get ubered out of new york and
so what did uber say uber said well we
have the people on our side and they
simply when you would pull up the app it
would basically be a blank screen it
would say if the government is
successful this is what the the app will
look like and so instead go sign up
petition go protest go you know like
like basically using a button there's a
button that you could press to
participate i think bradley tusk was a
was a huge piece of that uh shout out
bradley um and so when you think about
somewhere like ukraine
if you have the fourth highest per
capita crypto adoption anywhere in the
world
eventually you just say look are we
really going to go against what the
people want
right and it kind of leads the
conversation here in the united states
like there's regulators who are
basically making decisions that are
actually hurting
the population
in the united states there are
geo-fenced assets
there are yield assets that a u.s
consumer is not supposedly able to
access
how much money did the u.s consumers not
make because of the regulation
in many cases you would have made more
money by simply participating in the
crypto system
then they gave in stimulus checks
so you have to look at what is the will
of the people what do the people want
the government especially in democratic
uh environments serves at the will of
the people
the people should not fear the
government the government should fear
the people and so when you think of it
from that perspective ukraine most
likely is just simply saying hey we have
people who want to use this and so we've
got to make it legal we got to provide
clarification to the rules
and so when i look through kind of how
they're doing it what they did not do
was they did not make it legal tender
they did not do what el salvador did
they simply said it is legal for you to
buy it sell it hold it and it is also
legal for bless you excuse me and it is
also legal for you to run a business
that is related to it
which is kind of a first step towards
the country actually doing something but
it's essentially the equivalent of the
united states right it is legal for you
to buy and sell bitcoin in the united
states it is legal for you to build a
business around it and uh that's
essentially what they're doing right
here the economy in the ukraine is
massive especially when you think about
these other countries that have adopted
bitcoin right so el salvador for example
their gdp is 27 billion in 2019 and
ukraine's is 154 billion so it's very
very important i think the making of
these laws uh one thing i also want to
make clear because even just like the
way people were wording tweets yesterday
was i think trying to trick people in
the sense of that it was legal tender
and obviously it is not legal tender
they just legalize the operations for
individuals and businesses
but look all these laws they can help
regulate what's happening in the space
um and they can make these clear-cut
rules of hey this is loud this isn't
allowed or really complicated rules as
we see lawmakers like to do but it also
tramples innovation in the space right
so when you stop something from being
adopted it actually hurts your country i
think more um than the other side of
things
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you